[Applauso]
[Musica]
musica pronti però
no
[Musica]
il suono al caldo come il solo ma il
colore della notte ha un cuore o uguale
al nostro però batte più forte rughe sul
viso e dal sorriso di un bastardo guarda
la morte in faccia della morte abbassa
lo sguardo violenze bene le risposte che
sottrae e grido solo per la via con
mezzo ma mi da più di trent'anni per
questo parlo per la gente senza fiato
per chi non sa per quel sogno tempo
indeterminato in testa musica ma niente
tra le mani in cuffia capolinea piazzale
dei partigiani
scrivo per regge per chi vive alla
giornata scrive un'altra venerata sopra
i muri della strada scrivo una moto e
una parola io ci credo ancora scrivo
cuba libre non intendere un mccall a e
l'ho già detto che di fatto siamo in
tanti questa è musica rivoluzione dei
tre mostri inviati da vera musica chi la
tocca muore va oltre le parole
la tocca muore chi la tocca muore un
mostro musica le parole e la musica si
chiama la rivoluzione
io scrivo dio nella scifo all'uso il mio
tavolo non dormono e mi parlano con la
voce del diavolo mi sveglia di ogni
pasto lo trovò diverso più sarcastiche
col plastico che solo da diverso sangue
nuovo nell'arteria di questo quartiere
sono forte il suo nome roma non sono
bene giro con gente che la pensa come me
e la musica ci salva rapid casbah come i
plessi e meglio il cerchio intorno al
fuoco che il palco lontano è meglio
perdere la voce che parlare piano per
questo è raro che scriva testi al
passato perché ogni giorno struggle come
pezzo dei kalafro e in vecchi dischi
musicisti sanno cosa si è perché il
chitarrista vende l'anima ad un crocevia
e in vecchi dischi musicisti l'hanno
detto che la musica è la rivoluzione
nello specchio la vera musica sirai
pronta piano finale
il finale è corale mi raccomando
schieriamoci la voce musica pronti che
arriva all'ora
e quando dico musica di the rivoluzione
musica musica e quando dico musica di
the rivoluzione musica musica e quando
dico musica di the rivoluzione musica
musica musica musica musica
siete bellissimi edizione il mio fra
giudici e pastelli ai giradischi e
quando dico con sica ditte rivoluzione
musica voci chiare e quando dico musica
di the rivoluzione musicale musica se le
bellissimi fatevi un applauso tutti
coltissimi
[Musica]
musica evolutivo vivo arrivo rivoluzione
la prossima canzone che vi faccio
sentire ispirato a daniele ragazzacci
nelle carceri minorili parla del tempo
che non passa mai e si chiama orologi
molli si orologi molli loro sopra i
quali orologi molli si orologi molli
orologi molli loro sopra i crolli si
loro l'aci molle
ho scritto un libro nuovo parla di
essere liberi e trovare libertà in un
luogo fatto per non darne ho scritto un
libro per parlare ai miei simili ma
forse servirà qui a me ognuno alle
sbarre muore e non ti muovi da lì se
rimane a immaginare ad arginare troppe
lacrime ora l'ottimo a livelli di un
premio precario fuori orario su ste pace
questi ragazzi sono troppo uguali a me
una volta la voglia di atteggiarsi al
rapper la felpa dei lakers è quella loro
smani estrema non sempre mi ascolta
quando mi dico state a te di domani tra
breve o scrivi con il cuore in mano non
andrà lontano
però per farlo ed a strapparglielo dal
petto ma so per dirgliele mi dico adesso
vacci piano scuoto la testa e do
consigli che poi non rispetto e tutto
passa col tempo non so che cosa ma
qualcosa so che cambierà di certi errori
coach crescendo che mi ha passato per
passato se si mangia ma certo pasta e
tutto passa con un certo non so che cosa
ma qualcosa so che cambierà di certi
errori crescendo che gli ha passato si
che ti manca certo che ti manca mi manca
come solo a questa notte ghiacciata
ci manca come guardia cosa che non è
abbastanza eppure è così tanta che ti
strappa una risata
il vecchio mondo sta morendo ma il luogo
non nasce in mezzo a questo chiaroscuro
si affacciano i mostri ed io che più li
leggo gramsci p non mi do pace che ha
così dati manchi ancora la forza di
opporsi in mezzo ai lutti che si lascerà
alla pandemia pensa il peggiore sia di
fatto un'occasione persa quella di
mettere gli occhiali a una certa miopia
ed essere comunità oltre l'emergenza ma
ci assomiglia più di quanto andiamo a
mettere su questo presente di ignorante
vanità non lo cancelli riempiendo un
foglio di lettere tu non lo fai smettere
negando la realtà orologi molli orologi
molli o rosso tra i crolli orologi molli
orologi molli orologi molli mani strette
colli il tappo e tutto passa col tempo
non so che cosa fa qualcosa so che
cambierà di certi errori ben accolti
crescendo chiedi al passato se è passato
se ti manca già ma certo basta e tutto
passa con un certo non so che cosa va
qualcosa so che cambierà di certi errori
se ne accorgi crescendo
che sia passato si è passato se ti manca
cia o se ti manca già o se ti manca già
lo facciamo un applauso forza forza ma
sa bene che è il mio socio dj fazzone i
giradischi il prossimo pezzo e l'ultimo
con cui che salutiamo dice è ispirato a
una poesia di neruda e dice che mi
piacerebbe con i miei versi creare delle
cose si chiama lingua madre
che bel basso che piace pure a voi
ditemi se l'ebanista prende fiato soffio
trucioli dal tavolo in mente al suo
processo nelle dita il suo miracolo io
non sono contento delle frasi che
disegno finché il suono la parola sia di
lievito di legno e bada i paragoni con i
vecchi cantautori quasi tutti ora sono
vecchi dentro i prezzi fuori
l'era dei compromessi ci fa vivrei
riflessi spesso i rapper sono i primi
nemici di loro stessi per i ragazzi
siamo miti frasi sul diario il sogno
necessario del disordine ordinario ma
quando la luce spenta e l'adrenalina
estesa
mi chiedo quanto porta e la parola
faccia presa
mi chiedo quante volte poi ci siamo
contraddetti se li può pure il marketing
che riempie i palazzetti si pensa la
stessa penna con cui impari a rimare
scoccati d'inchiostro ti mostro la
lingua madre partire per restare rifare
vecchie strade combattere le noti pin
che si faranno chiare fino a quando
cuore stesso avranno gambe per andare
adelante io sto cercando la lingua madre
partire per restare rifare vecchie
strade combattere le no pt che si
faranno chiare fino a quando cuore
spesso avranno gambe per andare ad herat
io sto cercando la non credo e questo è
stato oggi come ieri
alle lapidi incise alle divise dei
carabinieri e la violenza e solo loro
noi non siamo uguali vecchia città nuove
retate nei centri sociali e loro oro il
nostro sangue non lo può comprare morti
al lavoro stessi fiori rossi sul lettore
suona a rosarno ed in sicilia suona in
tutto il sud e in val di susa
nell'acciaio della thyssen krupp
io quando scrivo l'inchiostro buca la
pagina il futuro e la poesia la fantasia
di chi lo immagina dopo vent'anni stessa
lotta stesso poco coniati e che via in
faccia come nel 94 e chi non urla non ha
voce oppure non ci crede ma il capitale
è sempre uguale e sempre in malafede
io faccio musica e so che il domani sia
nei segni sulla pazza sopra i palmi
delle mani per restare a rifare vecchie
strade per combattere le notti finché
non saranno chiare fino a quando resta
sapranno che a me per andare
adelante io sto cercando la lingua madre
partire per restare rifare sa da chi e
strade combattere le notifiche si
faranno chiare fino a quando cuore e
testa avranno gambe per andare
adelante io sto cercando la lingua madre
il mio caso di gekas terna davis
grazie di colore quanto è stato è un
piacere e un onore essere sul palco qui
con voi
permettetemi di salutarvi con gli ultimi
versi di questa serata è lo so non ve
l'aspettavate un sorpresone fa così
cercandomi tra i vicoli di incubi
grotteschi facce stanche erano teschi
notti bianche dostoevskij
io stesso nel riflesso dentro ai cerchi
del bicchiere la gente indifferente non
sente il tempo scadere presi la giacca
nonostante fosse aprile se l'odore di di
agazzi era l'ora di partire sul cavo
quella folla come le navi e di ulisse
straniero come il greco e come il ceco
che ne scrisse il mare nostro era
percorso da correnti appena baciato dai
venti perso tra gli elementi e gli umani
miei simili correvano contenti in mezzo
a piovere pescecani bravi schiavi dei
potenti una tribù fiera combatteva chi
comanda con l'ira del pelide achille gli
occhi di cassandra ma il tiranno
presidente lee represse come sempre
guardo il cielo mi convinco l'olimpo
indifferente senza la follia senza
poesia muori duri 24 ore
sei una instagram storie forse non siamo
nati per strisciare come bisce la
bestialità del logici fa porci come
circe e il mare non è dolce buio e rocce
sassi e sole a il sale delle lacrime e
quello del sudore ai soldi del mercante
la fame dell'emigrante lo sprezzo per lo
stato ad ogni lato un latitante andrà
moglie e musa la vera mi spingeva più al
largo di lampedusa
fogli scrive un disco tra gli scogli di
pietrisco tra le dita come anelli i
capelli di calipso e l'odissea ti prende
ti rende ostaggio so che itaca mi
attende però estenderò il mio viaggio
oltre le bocche d'ercole sfidando il
precipizio ancora troppo debole ma
pronto a un nuovo inizio in tasca avevo
solo quattro spicci
con lei ci parlavamo e parlavamo e
credevamo di capirci non avevo navi per
solcare quegli abissi presi un tronco
grezzo mi dissi costruisci le parole
dell'amore sono barche ma di carta e
come amare il marinaio e non volere che
riparta
a me basta penna carta foglio inchiostri
e una candela finché troverò penelope
amo solo questa vela
quando il sole il cielo si colora
aurora boreale cerco a sud pianeti e
stelle dalle spalle a lavorare soltanto
so chi sono quando scrivo alte materia e
la commedia umana io non rido navigatori
nomadi quei nodi negli stomaci non credo
alla sirena non sto a cena coi lotofagi
in piedi sopra il molo aspetto solo la
marea se stanotte non finissero servisse
un'altra odissea grazie sul serio bonato